you
hi everyone's Gerry I'm on Ches calm
right now and I'm playing a 3-2 game and
I was gonna go with d4 but and Knight f3
first and now d4 no big a big difference
so let's see what we get here oh okay
trying to squeeze a little bit more out
of that beep on instructing or
interfering with a c4 advance okay
hmm I think just ignore it and develop
eventually there'll be a tempo gained
after this move here so a6 I'm
anticipating and I could think about
moves like a 4 right now even yeah this
is maybe an interesting moment to play a
4 let's let's shoot for an a4 if b4 I'm
thinking about c4 yeah and maybe I want
to do that right now in fact okay let's
let's see how black reacts to that to
take or not this is a pond that's in my
position okay that are not doing
anything with that on Pontic so I was
going to just develop although it does
weaken before okay I'm already liking my
position I clearly cannot play to see
through with my knight and I don't want
to play b3 that weakens this Square too
much I have to be careful of an e5
advance so if I play my bishop here
let's let's do this move first Queen c2
I want to make sure I have a really good
control over this square I might want to
consider a5 at some stage but I'm gonna
get some more developing moves in okay
hmm
alright so I don't really want to allow
takes takes actually that wouldn't be so
bad would it really pawn takes pawn
takes Bishop to d3
hmm we're just Bishop d3 right away I
don't think there's anything wrong with
just Bishop to d3 right away let's go
for that you know that shouldn't be a
problem
Castle I'll keep the tension a little
bit to get some more moves in here my
opponents flying and after a rook to d1
maybe okay now let's see about maybe
capturing at this stage hm hm I don't
know where's this Queen gonna go hmm
rook to d1 pawn takes I'm gonna clarify
the the tension right now and maybe rook
d1 maybe I could run it like this
actually I should probably hang on
is this a move this might be an idea
maybe I can consider Knight to b3 yeah
let's let's play Knight to b3 put some
pressure on c5 Knight a5 is ruled out my
knight is no longer defended so I have
to be a bit careful at Bishop takes
Knight let's get this rook working I
don't know when I will go with this one
just in case a for needs some defense so
the Queen she's gonna have to find a
home and this is actually a little bit
uncomfortable she doesn't have the a5
square and on b6 I have a5 this Knight
cannot move because I have pressure on
h7 let's give her a kick has to be a
little bit uncomfortable and let's play
in the center I'm threatening to know
after this capture threatening to take
tonight and take h7 hmm probably just G
six right or hh6 don't know my night
feels a little bit awkward I must say
this might be a move mm-hmm no I don't
know about that
I gotta move a little bit faster here my
night yeah I don't really I'm not really
a great fan of my night maybe maybe it's
time for him to actually reposition
let's do this
hop into e4 you know that's true for
this now on rook takes Bishop I have
this in-between move I think at least
mm-hmm we're gonna find out they're
definitely gonna find out so he could be
actually a bit vulnerable if we get into
a dark square Bishop bending ah I didn't
consider that move at all huh okay I
gotta go with my my instincts here and
who really coming at me here um that's
actually a bit of a pain I think this
works out I have a tempo against this
Bishop at some point rook takes here
Queen takes Bishop takes Knight Queen d7
and I'm on the knight and the bishop
okay yeah I don't really want to weigh
down on time let's take care I have to
kick it into a higher gear this is very
ugly v2 is hit yeah this one definitely
got away hmm living off the increment
and I'm in a pin here as well got to
play b3 I'm giving up the c3 square
let's get that up and we're gonna have a
bunch of exchanges this pond feels like
it's just gonna drop any moment mm-hmm
do you not have a good feeling about
this button my bishop on e 2 is dead my
bishop on G 3 is just staring off into
space and the time is not looking so
great either ooh let's play this I'm
looking at a positional sacrifice now
rook to d5 they're probably going to
play into here I'll try and scare them
away with this yeah
okay so they're gonna give this up okay
well I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot for this
my dark squares are incredibly weakened
I realize but I'm going to try and get
some dark square control they could give
this check like at least it's something
to play for there's certainly an
advantage here it's easier for black to
play I think sink the bishop into this
point III you know let's play here off
of this diagonal Bishop d3 swing my
queen over I might want to just okay I
definitely don't do not want to allow h4
and break down my dark squares how to
untangle this is uh this is quite
difficult I think I'd like to just give
this pawn up if it's attacked it's just
so I could get some play maybe on the a
file I don't even know how I welcome
some exchanges it's still very locked
position these bishops are too strong
this Bishop on e3 is a monster but you
know let's play this for starters I have
to be careful g3 this is now pinned so
h4 is unprotected but okay yeah they
have that hmm that's a bit of a pain
let's do this and they got h4 on board
and I got to go faster and yeah this is
this is big trouble I'm done I got to go
here they're gonna have just a king move
and I'm toast to easy yeah I have to
throw in the towel here oh let's uh
let's have a look at this one with stock
fish and see where we could make some
improvements I don't know where I went
in this one so we're gonna have a look
ok stockfish help me out here
I need a lot of help I've seen this move
before this be five advance not only in
blitz but even and over the board play
and I played Bishop f4 in this game and
even in the over the board game in the
end I didn't really end up getting much
of an advantage it has about a half pawn
advantage at this point right now so
let's see how this plays out III
nothing's nothing's wrong here I went in
with that a4 move so doesn't have a
problem with that it's fine I played c4
or anything mm-hmm yeah there's a bit of
a drop off with that doesn't like c4 so
much just opting for a development
Bishop to d3 or even Knight B to d2 but
ok I can't be so bad can it right there
any great shifts here Queen C to D takes
e5 is something I eventually did miss
dad Bishop d3 still in bout an even ish
game hmm
okay knight c6
now I take knight b3 this got to be a
little bit awkward cuz when you look
back at the when you know we're
reviewing now what was this nice journey
d2 d3 and then he came back to d2 trying
to get into e4 so was this really
worthwhile can I save some time and not
go here should probably occupied the d
file right away that is that's what it's
calling for rook there with a knight h5
huh it's just blinking up there Bishop
takes h7 I move I'm just not going to
play more natural something like this
but
yeah okay just occupy the open file you
know two point two point three ish with
that move night be three you know even
where must've went wrong somewhere soon
though we're right around here doesn't
like that night move ah
he for why was there not considering e4
hmm you know this never entered my
thought process at all the idea of
changing the structure further I was
fixated on improving my pieces I had
this idea in mind of you know looking to
take the night and crash through here
that's not a great inconvenience to
black though and another way to even
look at this is it's helpful to black to
have this night traded because the
bishop can now see directly the White
King side so I'm really just helping
black out in uh you know looking at it a
bit more closely now with the time not
ticking ninety five is helping black out
helping the Bishop on b7 so better is
efore with a similar idea with a knife
here night here Knight takes Bishop
takes looking to remove the defender and
then crash through h7 but this is much
more direct efore with this in mind and
there is no follow-up of 'if I've here
they don't have enough support for that
hmm yeah I really should have clearly
considered a structural change I was
content with the the structure as is the
Queen side there's nothing doing there I
guess the only other upon most consider
is h3 but that's just a prophylactic
move of light square the only other one
I should be considering is a central
pawn advance didn't even cross my mind
during the game okay yeah that's where
there's a big shift to going from about
a half pawn advantage with this advance
calls for efore g6
and now yeah I could even start thinking
about infiltrating on these dark squares
what about on e4 h six
we got 85 Knight h5 Bishop e3 this
Knights a bit stranded and I have two
bishops pointing down at the black Kings
side yeah
this starts to be a bit more clear I
have ideas in mind of swinging this
Knight back over to e4 you know this
Knights a loose piece Queen to e2 a
knight move discovered attack against
the night okay noted I don't have to
play within the structure I can be
looking for some space advantage hmm
Bishop takes their lady to here yeah
it's kind of awkward to play still
liking maybe e4 Queen to e2 as well hmm
and it starts to drift right around here
yeah they do have a tactic oh really
just Bishop takes this is minus three
Bishop takes e4 Bishop takes oh man and
then b3 and this is with the pressure on
the d1 rook my queen is just stuck if I
go here rook takes rook and then Knight
takes bishop I'm down a piece so
deserved loss for sure this was a Miss
tacit I missed tactic by both of us hmm
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes in b3
interesting yeah we both missed that one
right there instead I'm still on my
heels I'm the worst side I wonder what
the computer has to say with that
imbalance I feel pretty confident that
it'll be saying black is it might
actually read that black is all right I
should say it'll be like an even
position let's maybe get to that still
even ish right now
he fours what I played here rook there
bishop f2 yeah Bishop takes yeah has it
as even but it really feels so much
easier to play in the black side and I
knew going into it my dark swears were
severely weakened that's why I played g3
Peter likes g3 Bishop check King up
mm-hmm
alternative King G - yeah I didn't want
to do that but I guess looking at it a
bit more
I'll played out in the game the the dark
squares and this idea of the H pawn
advanced it's a good one it's one of
those where you know you could really be
a nice a battering-ram he I kind of view
this H pawn is the expendable one of the
kingside pawns you can move him forward
no additional squares are really
weakened around the black Kings side and
it's just a nice aggressive pawn and he
does some good things could damage the
White King side structure you know dark
squares got broken down h4 it still has
it okay now it's starting to climb here
giving it some time to think it's even
calling out for g5 right now I popped up
at one point Queen b8 Bishop d3 g 5 yeah
g5 is good nice move g5 takes h4 I saw
coming but I had to do something
different here clean here and yeah
that's the ball game H takes King h1 I
can't play here because of this yeah and
the rook is soon to occupy the H file
mm-hmm oh well yeah the main one here I
guess how I played it with a 4 c4 not
bad although you know we'll actually
hang in let me back up for a moment it's
easy to get rattled with these awkward
type moves but you kind of play it
simply go about things where I go about
development where
you just kind of ignore it and you could
say to yourself you know what eventually
when I play e3 I'll be gaining a tempo
and black will have to respond and that
costs black something so try not to get
too rattled as what I'm getting at if
you see in a typical move a 4c form yeah
I should have went with the structural
change I didn't consider it at all
rook here a queen move and start
thinking about a pawn push I do have
these bishops here pointing at the black
Kings side I didn't consider the
structural change and that really cost
me and also this point right here again
trading the Knights I'm really just
helping out the bishop unmasking the
bishop and they had that tactical shot
on e4 that was a cool one with in b3
that's cool yeah tough one okay as usual
feel free to leave any comments in the
comment section below to this video and
I'll catch you in the next one that's
all for now take care bye